hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast discovering cellular
mechanisms and markers in anti pd-1
non-responders through ingenuity pathway
analysis and uncle and presented by dev
mystery senior filled application
scientists bioinformatics kyochon I am
Alexis Krause of laberd's and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring into the educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by kyochon for more
information about our sponsor please
visit Keoghan calm before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left to your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and the software's
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
mystery I will now turn the presentation
over to him
thank you for the kind introduction so
today we'll be looking at two different
software one is in Georgia pathway
analysis and another one is uncle n from
foam Excel and we will learn how the
software can be used to discover
cellular mechanism and biomarkers and
pretty much any data set but for this
presentation will focus on anti pd-1
non-responder data set from renal cell
carcinoma
agenda the main objective for the study
is to identify biomarkers regulators
targets and mechanism action from an NGS
data set now this data set can again be
a user data set or publicly available
data set in this case we're going to use
a publicly available data set for n type
Evo and non-responders this presentation
is divided into two parts in the first
part we'll be focusing on data mining so
we'll be using uncle and from omics oft
for data mining so I'll introduce you to
the software I will find a good data for
n type a1 non-responder from this
software and then we'll study how the
software can be used to identify
biomarkers by looking at the expression
across different tumor tissue from
public sources such as TCGA G text and
so on and then in addition to that this
software can also be used to generate
different views so to see how good the
biomarkers are you can generate curves
with the survival curves heat map and so
on in the second part of the software
we'll be focusing on data interpretation
and in this part we'll be looking at
integer data analysis software so I'll
introduce you to the second software and
the data base backing the software and
then intrinsic pathway analysis is
mainly used for interpretation so we'll
look at like okay if you have a gene
expression data how this is my position
data is associated with pathways master
regulators and how you can also be used
to discover biomarkers and doing
comparison and then we will end with a
summary
to say you're using your own data set in
this case what you'll be doing is you'd
be using pipeline that is offered by a
studio by chiasm and this pipeline will
allow you to do things like
pre-processing the data you see the data
aligning your reach of the reference if
you are using like RNC or NGS data and
then gene transcript ocation and then
finally if your data has experimental
groups like this versus normal treated
versus untreated then you can use
statistical tools available within the
software to do comparison and once you
do all that you can generate various
plots that are shown on the screen over
here so you can generate principal
component analysis and principal
coordinate allows this plot you can also
generate a volcano volcano plot which is
in the center of the screen and you can
also generate heat map which is on the
lower right corner of the screen now
many users not only they use their own
data set but they're also interested in
locating interesting public data set and
if you're one of the users like that
then what you'd probably have to do is
you would have to download the data from
public domain so this data can be
gigabyte if not terabytes after you
download you would have to align the
reads to the reference for this data
if this is an RSV NGS data and then you
would quantify gene and transcript
expression you do differential
expression as I mentioned in my previous
slide so you would have to do all of
this by yourself now if you're
interested in curating multiple public
data from multiple sources then in
addition to doing all of this you would
also help to curate metadata for this
data so each data set will have
description right where is it coming
from
what tissue is it coming from what cell
line is it coming from if it is coming
from patient then always the patient
treated with both the concentration of
drugs so you would have to kill it all
of this information
fortunately our team at omics off has
already done this from many different
public sources so this will be sources
to test the Cancer Genome Atlas TCGA
which has a lot of cancer dataset geo
PCL ECC alias ccle has a lot of
line dataset gtex which is a lot of
normal tissue data set so our team has
already done all of this process for you
which can take months if not years
depending on the resources you have and
another thing our team is regularly
doing is they're regularly maintaining
this database and they're also updating
this regularly they're updating this
quarterly so now say your user and you
are focusing on something like PD one
period one interaction for those of you
who don't know PD one PDL one Pete this
interaction is one of the immune
checkpoint PDL is expressed on certain
tumor tissue and it is known that this
interaction can suppress the immune
system so that's why there are so many
therapies that are focused on blocking
this interaction so one of the antibody
drugs that is out there is novel you map
from BMS and it is known to block PD
1 and it is also known to be used in
indication such as melanoma non-small
cell lung carcinoma renal cell carcinoma
and other indication now the problem
with such treatment is it is beneficial
for many patients but it does not apply
to all the patients so there are many
PDL one expression
expressing tumors that don't respond to
the therapy so that's why I decided to
pick a data set which compares
non-responder population to responder
population so now the question is I
introduced you to onyx offline database
how can we use this land database to
locate such a data so as I mentioned
this land database has donation from
many different public sources and one of
the sources if you look at the left hand
corner of the screen is geo geo has tons
and tons of public data set and these
are curated in the land database so
since we have curated all of this data
you can actually search for them by
different keywords you can use keywords
appear missus name drug name etc so over
here I have a screenshot from the soft
which you can see and in the screenshot
you can type in the name of the drug so
and the previous screen we have my
volume app so you can start typing
narrowly map and some hits will come up
if you click on any one of the hits then
you can actually locate different
projects that have used niala map in
their study so at the bottom of the
screen I have a list of study that have
used my volume app and since we have
also created a metadata from the study
you can see what institutions are the
study coming from you can also read the
general description of the study and
more importantly in the bottom center of
the screen we have some web link to the
study so you can click on the web links
and you can read actual extract data
description and so on so that's what I
did I actually read through the
description of the studies abstracts of
the study and even some papers and then
I realized that the project that's
listed over here the ID g SE six seven
five zero one it's kind of highlighted
in the center of the thing it was an
interesting project interesting white
because in this study investigators are
working with patients that have
metastatic renal cell carcinoma and they
are treated with nivel you map now this
patients are classified as responders
and non-responders
based on response evaluation criteria in
solid tumors and then what authors have
done from this patient is they have
extracted RNA from PDL 1 plus tumor
tissue so they have extracted that from
poor responders and eight non-responders
and then later on they have perform
microarray analysis on it so they have
performed gene expression on office
using alumina B chip some of you may be
interested in checking out these papers
I have included a screenshot at the
bottom so please feel free to check it
out
now one of the things you are focusing
on is mile markers and target so if you
look at that then you might be curious
how you can open up this gene expression
data and look at different biomarkers
and target so over here we have opened
up this data set in form of volcano plot
and what
plot is in the center of the screen and
on the on the right hand side you also
have this data available as a
differential expression table and in
differential expression table what you
see is a list of gene with cold changes
p-value adjusted p-value and so on and
in walk you plot what you see is on the
x-axis we have lock for change for
different genes so if you go from 0 to
right hand side you have genes are
increasing in expression and if you go
from 0 the left hand side you have genes
are decreasing in expression also if you
look at the y-axis we have antilog of
p-value so if you go from 0 to upward on
y-axis then you have genes are more and
more significant so if you think about
it genes that are present in the upper
right corner of the screen this is going
to be the genes are upregulated and
significant and then genes are present
in the upper left corner of the screen
are going to be the genes are down
regulated and significance
so now let's see if we can focus on
non-responder population so again if we
look at the volcano plot this volcano
plot is comparison of responder versus
non-responders so if you focus on the
upper left corner of the screen then you
see jeans that are down regular
junker up regulated and responder and
significant and this paper particularly
mentioned you gt1 a six as well as the
key genes because this gene is involved
in metabolic and solute transport
functions so if you can read about this
scene online then you know that this
gene what it does is it processes
steroids drugs etc into water-soluble
molecules that can be excreted from the
cell and this is what the paper is
proposing that this is one of the main
mechanism by which non-responder may not
be responding to therapy but in addition
to ugt one is take there are other genes
of the family they are present in
non-responder population as well
so so far what we have seen is we have
been introduced you we have introduced
you to on : database on : database has
information from many different public
sources such as TCGA SRA geo and so on
we have also introduced you how this
database can be used to locate
interesting data so in our case we have
located data which is non-responder
versus I'm sorry responder persist
non-responder and then now what we are
going to look at is can we study
different biomarkers using a different
information that's available in this
database so for this now we are going to
focus on you gt1 a family members
because that's one of the things that's
described in the paper and in the later
part of the presentation we're going to
move away from UTG one and we are going
to focus on other teams as well that are
not described in the paper so last time
we looked at Uncle to database this time
we're going to look at the Cancer Genome
Atlas database and in this database the
data we have curated what you can do is
you can search for a gene or marker of
your interest and see how this gene is
expressed across different tissues so on
the y-axis we again have gene expression
and I'm sorry on the x-axis we again
have gene expression and on y-axis we
have different tumors so what you see
over here is you gt1 a six is expressed
more in carcinoma which is leaner cell
carcinoma and hepatocellular carcinoma
and it's expressed relative less in
carcinomas which is acute myeloid
leukemia so in some ways it is it does
seem to be expressed more in the local
carcinoma compared to other tumors if
you think about is marker application
now the thing is not everyone is going
to be interested in all of these
diseases many times people want to focus
on specific diseases so for example this
study is based on another carcinoma so
within the software we also have filters
which you can use to focus on specific
indication in this case I have only
selected one indication
renal cell carcinoma but in your case
say if you wanted to select multiple
indication like you want you wanted to
compare the
versus acute then you could select more
and you can only help those role visible
in the software
another thing you'll notice is on this
plot we have two types of colors blue
and green so blue are the different
tumor samples that are curated
complicity and green are different
normal samples are curated from TCGA so
another thing a lot of users are
interested in doing is splitting this
role based on the metadata so in this
case the metadata would be tumor versus
normal it is also very easily doable in
the software you can change the grouping
by few click and you can flip this one
screen into a split this one row into
two rows so now we see tumor versus
normal comparison and you can see
difference is not that create but there
does seem to be some difference between
tumor and normal tissue so in this case
another thing we can check on is over
here tumor is just like one thing but in
reality that different stages of tumors
and this meta data is also available in
TCGA and because this is available in
TCGA because we have curated it you can
now split that single row of tumor into
multiple row of stages so now we have
pathological stage one two three and
four and again the pattern you'll notice
is there is some difference between a
tumor and normal and you know the
difference between stage is honestly
it's minimal but this is only for one
marker usually one a say what about
other family members so now when we move
on to another family member you g21 a
tree you can see this bigger difference
between its expression in tumor and its
expression in adjacent normal tissue so
keep in mind that this is TCGA so normal
over here is the adjacent normal tissue
and then again just like you do you want
a six if you split this into different
stages just to see if this marker is
specific to one stage or more what
you'll see is there is bigger difference
between normal and Stage one but there's
more difference across different stages
but at the same time if you go from
normal to Stage four then the difference
is becoming greater and greater giving
it potential as a biomarker
so as I pointed out in one of the
previous slide the normal tissue we've
been looking at so far is normal that's
adjacent to tumor and a lot of
investigators don't like that about TCGA
because they feel that the normal tissue
does next to tumor may or may not be
normal but what they want to do is they
want to compare the expression of this
gene from tumor samples from TCGA and
normal sample from gtex data base which
is scholarly for normal tissues okay and
because our team has diligently curated
information from all of these databases
you can actually do this cross database
comparison and another thing to note is
you are only able to do this comparison
because our team has gone through
trouble of reprocessing all of this
expression data using the same pipeline
for now I have similar plot but now we
are looking at two different databases
we have TCGA on the top and we have G
text at the bottom and what you see is
there is difference between expression
of ugt 180 between tumor and normal in
TCGA and there is lesser difference
between normal of TCGA and G Tesco or
all this difference between expression
of ugt 180 of normal gtex and TCGA and
tumor of TCGA and on the lower right
corner of the screen you can see I have
also turned on the statistical test
which is kanoa F test and according to
this the difference we see across groups
is significant so this is another thing
a lot of users like to do when they are
using on coal and they like you turn on
the static statistics and see if the
difference looking at is real or not so
summary for so far is we looked at two
markers ug t 1 hp and ug 1 a 6 we looked
at this two markets because according to
the non-responder versus responders
study this markers are more prevalent in
a non responder and another thing we
noticed is for you gt1 a 6 there was
less difference for usually 1 Hz there
was more difference when we compared
between tumor and normal
nevertheless when you compare across
different tumors usually to a markers
are expressed
more in renal cell carcinoma compared to
other tumors and another thing I did not
go or much but you as a user can do is
you can go beyond TCG and Detex you can
also use databases at SCC le which I
have highlighted highlighted in the
center of my screen and using severely
data later which uses cellular
information in the sense that you GT one
a six which is one of the markers is
expressed more in kidney cell line
compared to other cell lines that just
say long or breast and so on so now we
can ask another question are these
markers associated with survival and
because the study is emphasizing greatly
on you gt1 a six I have picked that
marker so another thing you can do a non
: software is you can divide things into
groups so the way I have divided
information over here is I have divided
samples into high expression of ugt one
a six marker which is the top row and
low expression of ugt one a six marker
so basically if I define a cut-off of
50% and I have mentioned to software
that okay all the samples that have 50%
or higher expression make them high and
all the samples that have 50 percent or
lower expressions make them low and even
though you might think that there are
more samples in high versus low it's not
the case in both things I just clustered
very close to each other so there are
about equal number of samples in high
group and low group so within software
once you group this very easily by one
or two quick you can also generate
survival curves and this is something I
know is of great interest to many of our
users so what they want to do is they
want to compare the survival when you GT
one basic or marker of the interest is
high versus marker that interest is low
and in this case what you see is when
you have high expression of GGG one a
six then you have relatively poor
survival as opposed to that when you
have low expression of you gt1 a stakes
this is across all the tumors in TCGA as
opposed to just renal carcinoma but at
the same time you can see if you look at
the statistics we have a significant
value if you focus on the upper-right
corner of the screen now if we limit
this to just you know that carcinoma so
again three group samples based on high
and low expression only in renal cell
carcinoma and then generate so our curve
is in the software then you will see
similar pattern which is samples that
have high expression or fugitive on a
stick we'll have poor survival compared
to that samples that have low expression
of ug 2 1 8 6 have better survival so I
mean one can always ask the question
that is [ __ ] you want a six is
actually associated with survival or not
so in the last two slides to summarize
what we learned is within the software
you can generate group so in this case
we generated groups based on expression
of marker uj2 and a six and what we
learned is overall when you have higher
expression of this marker than this core
survival whether you're looking across
all tumors or whether you're looking
across renal carcinoma
now what I want to mention over here is
this is just one way of dividing data
based on expression marker but you can
also divide data based on other
parameter so we have curated metadata
right so we also have curated
histological data so based on that
histological data you can also divide
tumors in to say her to positive versus
how to negative or you can do triple
negative breast cancer versus non triple
negative breast cancer some people
instead of working with expression
markers they work with mutation markers
so they would divide data into tp53 wall
type for certificates emitted the key is
once you divide samples into this group
you can generate wide ranges of plots so
in the lower left corner of the screen
I have survivor plot but in addition to
that once you divide things into groups
you can also generate gene expression
heat map so in the lower right corner of
the screen I have an example of gene
expression heat map which compares a
TCGA TCGA tumor tissue to both TCGA and
gtex normal tissues so TCGA and gtex
normal
shoot is clustered around the center of
the heat map where you see a lot of red
which means the jeans are going up and
the same things are going down in tumor
tissue so you can also come up with good
markers by generating such heat map so
in part one we focus on data mining
more specifically we learned about the
land database we learned how it can be
used to locate a data set of interest in
our case it was the n-type ed1
non-responder dataset and we also
learned how it can be used to study
various biomarkers and target in this
case we have mainly focused on ug t one
a six and usually one a 3 because these
are two of the two of the enzymes are
mentioned in the paper but we can go
well beyond that as well now in part two
we are going to again focus on data
interpretation so for data
interpretation I'm going to first
introduce you to enjoy deposit and also
software and its database and then we
are going to go into things like how it
can be used to learn about mechanism of
action in non-responder how it can be
used to generate causal network and
non-responder how it can be used to
discover potential new biomarkers and
target targets both for looking at
pathways and through comparison analysis
when we looked at that volcano plot
earlier right that what kind of plot had
mannequins did not just have you gt1 a
six but they had managing they're going
up and down and one can always ask
question okay you just spent half the
presentation talking about one gene what
about the other gene so this is where we
can actually use software such as injury
deposit and assets effectively what
injury Department office will do is it
will actually take the whole gene list
and based on that it will show you what
pathways are enriched for the chinless
so what pathways are associated that
gene lists what diseases and biological
processes are associated with the gene
is if you look at the right hand corner
of the screen you can actually open up
the pathway if you look at the chart
where you see left one you can also
compare expression of different
different biomarkers on the pathway and
if you look at the modern of the screen
then you can compare your radius dataset
and you can also compare your data set
with public data set in the sense that
you want to know what pathways are
active and inhibited across all of this
data set what diseases and functions are
active and inhibit across all of these
data sets so this other thing we are
going to do but all of these things are
only possible because of the data base
that's backing IPA and this is what we
call knowledge base so in this knowledge
base our PhD level curators what they
have done is they have curated
information from peer-reviewed
publications and they have also curated
information from third party data
sources now keep in mind a lot of this
information that is curated from ple
publications is manually curated by PLL
scientists and we just updated on weekly
basis on the other hand the data the
information we create from databases
like bio grid clinical trials.gov
tar base so you know these are the
databases for things like protein
protein interaction clinical trials
micro Ronnie
this information is updated on quarterly
basis so all in all our curators keep
the database as up-to-date as possible
so you get as up-to-date an office as
possible now keep in mind we mainly
create information from human mouse and
rat but saying that if you are working
with other
fish species like bovine chickens in
Ponte you can still use IPA as a matter
of fact if you go to scholar.google.com
and search for IPA with this other
species you'll find plenty of
publication
one thing that is also unique about this
database is you're giving it a gene or
gene list and what it's doing is
connecting these different genes and
proteins so in addition to making those
connection it will actually give you a
lot of contextual information so over
here I have on the right hand side this
chart connecting ìokay protein to
predicate one protein and what you see
over here is there is an edge connecting
them which is pp bracketry so PT stands
for protein protein interactions so
first of all just by looking at a
network of pathways you'll know that
this is a specific type of interaction
and three stands for number of sources
that support this interaction in
addition to that by few clicks you can
go from that line to the findings that's
in the upper right corner of the screen
over here and looking at the findings
you can quickly see what literature is
this interaction coming from you can
click on the hyperlink and go to the
literature itself you can also see what
type of experiments did the author do to
derive this information you can see what
species they use human what's a line we
use human platter ate so the information
we have in this database is very contact
and contextual and just to drop
contracts from the previous database
which is the on colon database and on
potato-based
our curators have curated actual NGS
data as opposed to that in IPA database
we have curated fine links or knowledge
so basically basically in IPA database
our curators are reading through papers
and then they are collecting information
from text and figures as opposed to that
in on colon database we have curated
actual data that's one of the biggest
differences between these two database
and that's why this are very
complementary to each other so in the
last few minutes what I have done is I
have introduced you to internally
pathway analysis database and I have
also drawn contrast with omics of
database and again the contrast is in
omics web database we have curated
actual data in IPA database we create
knowledge from text and figures
so
before I start showing you pathways in
IPA I want to go through some color
codes so over here you see a couple of
different colors and I want to emphasize
on four of them two are red and green
and other two are orange and blue red
and green are actual measurements so red
are the genes and proteins are going to
be upregulated in your data set green
are the genes and proteins are going to
be down regulated in your data set as
opposed to that orange and blue our
prediction for orange other things that
are predicted to be active according to
IPA and ideas drawing this prediction
based on the information it has
collected from previous literature and
then blue other things are predicted to
be inhibited so now if we walk through
some examples we see MSD one in the
center of the screen connected to
apoptosis MSD one is red that means it's
up regulated in the specific gene
expression data that we are studying and
this is leading to increased apoptosis
I'm saying increase because if artosis
is colored orange so MSD expression is
the actual data apoptosis Orange is the
prediction as opposed to that if you
look at the center of the screen bad
it's color green so bad is down
regulated in your data set and this is
leading to inhibition of apoptosis
because apoptosis is color blue and then
finally just to give you one more
example just to you know make sure we
get this colors down TTFN alpha is color
red that means TTF alpha is upregulated
in the specific data that we are looking
at and erbb2 is colored orange Stepney's
up regulation of TTF alpha leads to
activation of ele b2 according to
information that IPA has curated from
previous literature okay so again red
and green actual measurements orange and
blue prediction now that we have this
down let's look at pathways
this week let's look at pathways so over
here
what we have is pathways that are
enriched in non-responder population so
what I have done is I have taken that
omics off data and I have uploaded
non-responder versus responded
comparison in IPA ok and then if we look
look at the name of the pathway you
should immediately see the allowance of
some pathways for example second two
topic weights molecular mechanism cancer
in this non-responders we expect cancer
to be on and that's why that pathway
makes sense in addition to that there
are also positive DNA methylation and
transcription repression signaling in
the center of the screen and in cancer
you know such things are supposed to
happen so we can expect that as well now
some other pathways may or may not make
sense for example there's external
guidance signaling on the top and you
would think that hey this is a real data
set why do we see that passing but the
passes that don't make sense they're
like kind of colored in blue over here
these pathways are related to function
purchased out route growth factors
information style cycle and all of this
things are related to cancer so it makes
sense that this pathways show up has
stopped it for non-responder data set
what we can do to study mechanism of
action in non-responder is we can
actually open up one of the pathways so
in this case in software I'm clicking on
molecular mechanism of cancer and I'm
opening up that pathway and when we open
up the pathway if you're looking at IPS
facet for the first time one thing
you'll notice is passes are very nicely
organized from plasma membrane to
cytoplasm to nucleus and for this
specific pathway we have plasma membrane
on the both side of the screen on the
top of the screen as well as bottom of
the screen right so let's zoom in to
this pathway and learn more about it
what's happening so again remember the
color orange and blue our prediction red
and green are actual measurements if you
focus in the very center of the screen
where it says DNA repair and go two
steps down then we have a gene that is
colored in red so red means it is
upregulated in the data in your data set
so this gene seems to activate gene that
is downstream of it and that activation
seems to need to increase DNA repair in
addition to that we see that
differential expression of other genes
seems to lead to increased cell cycle
regulation and decrease apoptosis if you
focus on red circles that I have drawn
on this pathway so now we have bigger
picture now we are not like looking at
just one team we are looking at multiple
genes and we are learning how these
multiple genes are leading to things
like increased DNA repair increased cell
cycle regulation and reduce apoptosis
and all the things would be of course
important in knowledge corner population
and then if you look at the bottom half
of the place then again we have left one
color red and that seems to lead to
increased cell survival and this is the
section that I have highlighted in red
in the center of the screen and I'm
going to talk to you with more about
left one in the following slide so what
we learned so far is using this pathways
are provided by entry path and office we
can see how gene expression your data
set is connected to specific processes
such as DNA repair apoptosis cell cycle
regulation and so on now we have two
groups over here right we have non
responders and we have responders so can
we compare those groups in IPA so that's
the question we are asking over here
so in this case you can see what you can
do an idea by a few clicks is you can
turn on this bar chart so next to left
one I have this March art and I have
group number one and group number two
group number one by the way is non
responders and group number two is
responded and you can see left one is up
in non-responder and left one is down in
responders and if you know about left
one left one is a very well-known marker
for cell survival and it has been known
to be important for cell survival for
many different cell lines and as
expected it is up in non-responders and
it just mound in responders but this is
a well-known marker what about other
markers so in ip8
for specific pathways and networks you
can also generate heat maps like the one
I have shown on the right hand side of
the screen so now we are not just
looking at left one but we are looking
at many other genes with this we see
env2 piece and - and many others so all
of these teams are up in non-responders
and down in squanders and i'm sorry i
have switched the column header but red
column is the knowledge ponder and green
column is the responder so now we can
also potentially propose other
biomarkers that may be specific to
responders and non-responders
and then a next thing we can ask is okay
we were doing comparison on a single
pathway can we do more for global Global
comparison can we compare multiple
passes at the same time so in IPA you
can actually do that so over here I have
compared activation and inhibition of
all of the pathways in non-responder
versus responder so the first column in
the centre of the screen that's orange
is non-responder and the second column
is responder and you can see a lot of
cancer-related pathways are active in
non-responder and they're inhibited in
responder so they get this can also help
you propose a hypothesis why non
responders are resisting the therapy and
even though I have opened up a different
pathway in this case it's il-7 signaling
pathway as opposed to molecular
mechanism of cancer pathways that we saw
in previous slides you see similar
conclusions that apoptosis law bottom of
the screen proliferation is off bottom
right of the screen and on the left-hand
side of the pathway you also see altered
metabolism which is also one of the
characteristics of the cancer so again
it's a different pathway but conclusions
are very similar like you know why
normos wonders are not responsive
responding to get therapy because if opt
OSes off subtitle is wrong proliferation
is on and then there is also altered
metabolism which is in agreement with is
with with what is discussed in the paper
so one of the other things many users
like to do is they like to compare their
data set to public data set so why would
you want to do that so here's the thing
we are looking at only one renal
carcinoma study right but there are many
other studies that have also used you
know carcinoma samples but if you
compare your study to this public study
you can maybe strengthen your hypothesis
so for this can IPA we have introduced
an office mash tool and analysis match
tool can either allow you to compare
various analysis that you have so say
you have 30 patients 50 treatments you
can compare them side-by-side
using an office match or it can also
allow you to compare your data with
public data which is what I'm doing over
here I am comparing the data that I
found from the study to other public
renal carcinoma dataset and what we see
is many of the regulator's that are
found by IPA are similarly activated
between the renal carcinoma dataset we
are looking at as well as many other
public data set so this feature is one
of the newer features in IPA it's called
an optic mat and it's a very powerful
tool to compare how different pathways
different regulators different
biological processes are similarly or
differentially activated and inhibited
across different offices so what else
can we learn about this regulators and
target so in IPA we have this feature
called causal network analysis and
causal network analysis feature both
focuses greatly on master regulators
alright so there are many causes on the
screen right now but the left hand side
column is the column with all of the
predicted regulators by IP and on the
very right hand side column where you
see a lot of genes these are the genes
are downstream of this regulators and
are present in your data set okay so in
this case the data that we are looking
at is non-responder data set so if I
were to give you an example of a role
then the very first row ways to see are
e vb p you know so cre b BP would be a
master regulator the very first row
watch is telling me that cre bv p is a
transcription factor it is predicted to
be activated by IP a and it is
regulating 375 genes in this
non-responder data set according to the
information that is curated from the
literature so that's what the first row
is telling me and I have actually filter
this table for specific genes so I have
first of all filters this table for only
genes and proteins as opposed to drugs
and chemicals so because I take can also
predict whether you know genes in your
data set can be regulated by selling
drugs in chemicals so I have filtered
this table for genes and proteins and
then I have also filtered this table for
genes that are significantly up and
down by the criteria I have defined
which is the lock to ratio 0.58 which
converts into full change of 1.5 so when
we apply this filter we actually see
many interesting transcription
regulators as upstream master regulators
and these are the regulators are in the
center of the screen and you can see all
of these regulators are predicted to be
active and then if I were to open up
networks for them you would see that all
of these are also actually connected to
activation of renal carcinoma if you are
one of the users who is focusing on
mechanism action then this can be of
great help and then below all of the
transcription factors we see couple of
enzymes which is key FP t 1 and s and
why D 3 right so if you're one of the
users who are looking for master
regulators there are targetable
molecules because you are doing things
like drug discovery and so on then you
may want to focus on these genes there
are enzymes because enzymes are
targetable not to say transition
regulators are not but in general like
you know my conversation with different
pharma and biotech you know in terms of
small drug small molecules they prefer
something like enzyme as opposed to
transcription factors so all of these
activated factors when I do enrichment
analysis on them they are actually
connected with cancer in one form or
another a lot of them all are also
connected with processes such as a cell
cycle
DNA repair and then in terms of this
enzyme one of the ones that piqued my
interest was GFP t 1 I focus on GFP t 1
because in engineering knowledge base it
is created that this enzyme has been
previously associated with diseases such
as prostate cancer or be seeking
diabetes and then when we look at the
causal network it provides us with an
explanation that how activation of this
enzyme is leading to increase in renal
cell carcinoma phenotypes so what we see
on this causal network is
GFP t 1 when it's active it is leading
to activation of other regulators such
as tgf-beta 1
USF - and pyaar ka and then this
activation is leading to activation of
downstream oncogenes such as make and
then also 50:53 and then this is leading
to increase email cutting a renal cell
carcinoma phenotype so now as a user you
can propose a hypothesis and if you're
interested in discovering target then G
F G a G s PT one can also serve as a
potential target
finally before I wrap up my talk for
those of you who are interested in like
biomarker discovery we have tools such
as Maya profiler and when you use this
tools in IPA by profiler you can
actually connect different teams and
proteins are present in the data set
with specific phenotype that you're
looking at so in this case we are
connecting the differential gene
expression in non-responder to renal
cell carcinoma and using that we are
figuring out that B 2 B 2 n is one of
the markers that's expressed in renal
cell carcinoma is also transmembrane
receptors and if your previous like you
know where is this information created
from an IPA things are very easy you can
either double-click on the lines that
connecting different genes or you can
click on the hyperlink that's on the
right hand side of this table and you
can open up this findings page so on the
lower right corner of the screen you see
finding and you can figure out like you
know what paper or what source is
information coming from so to summarize
in the second part of this talk what we
did is first of all we generated
hypotheses for mechanism of action for
that we looked at pathways such as
mechanism the cancer pathway and I'll
say on signaling pathway and we also
look at causal network such as G at Pt 1
all right so using that we propose
certain mechanisms action in terms of
how the new cell carcinoma phenotype is
on in non-responder data set for
biomarkers we also looked at cell for
cell survival markers such as left one
and then in addition to that we also
discovered potential new markers that
are shown in the heat map on the screen
and then another thing we learned for
IPA is it can also be a powerful tool
for comparison so you can compare your
data with your other data but you also
can compare an office of your data with
analysis of a data set from public
domain such as TCGA geo SRA and so on
one thing I did not cover is actually
shown on the right hand side of the
screen where I'm using an example then
IPA can also be
when you don't have any data set so in
that case they if you were the author of
the paper and you want to quickly figure
out how you gt1 a six is connected to
remote cell carcinoma that even without
any data you could draw the network that
is strong in the lower right corner of
the screen and you could propose
hypothesis so overall summary for this
presentation would be we looked at two
software one is on colon from omics walk
and second one is intuitive pathway
analysis from ingenuity both comic soft
and ingenuity are part of Kaizen both of
this software has their own unique data
base so in land database our curators
help curated information from public
sources such as TCGA fr and geo and so
on and again they have created actual
data and they have reprocessed all of
this NGS data especially the gene
expression data using the same pipeline
as opposed to that in ingenuity our PLL
curators what they're doing is they're
curating knowledge so they are reading
text and figure from the journal and
they're creating knowledge so using this
knowledge in both of the software you
can do wiring use of things go in uncle
and we looked at how you can see the
expression of a gene across different
tumor samples tumor versus normal
samples different stages of tumor
you could even locate and interesting
later so that's how we found the
non-responders versus responder data set
for renal cell carcinoma and then we
also generated thoughts like survival
curves I did not generate heat map but
that's also something very easily doable
in on colon and for IPA what we learned
is mechanism of action so we open up
different pathways that allow us to
generate hypotheses for mechanism
actually and non-responder we also
looked at biomarkers and we also did
some powerful comparison using this tool
called analysis match alright so with
that I will conclude my presentation and
if you guys have any questions I am
happy to take them right now thank you
dr. mystery for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers
you have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left to your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email so let's
get started our first question is can
you talk about the export options for
different views that you showed in your
presentation
yes great question so everything I've
shown right so this is a concern that
brought up by many of the users when
they actually start using our software
that you know they use some other
software in the past and that don't
allow export so pretty much all the
views are shown they can be exported as
high resolution images and especially
for things like in duty passes and all
because if you go to scholar.google.com
you see plenty of publications that side
IPA and use view they are generated by
IPA so all of the views are exportable
they're basically export button on top
of the screen you would just click on it
and then you choose things like you know
what type of image you want do you want
JPEG or PNG and in case of IPA you can
also adjust a resolution to really high
resolution like 300 dpi 16 dpi and so on
so everything is exportable yes now
doctor mystery how regularly different
databases in your talk are updated
another great question so yeah I have
been talking a lot like you know
different databases I've been talking
about uncle and data base from omics awk
and I've been talking about injury
database for IPA
so uncle and database currently is
updated on quarterly basis and in
futures our developers are hoping that
they can increase the speed of this
update and IPA database the information
that's curated from literature is
actually updated on weekly basis on the
other hand information that we curate
from different third-party databases
like bio grade clinical trials.gov is
updated on quarterly basis so we can in
summary say that the all the major
updates are happening on the quarterly
basis and another thing I want to
mention over here is we not only update
risk knowledge and information but we
also update in terms of new features so
a lot of things I showed you especially
in IPA in the later half of the
presentation like bar chart heat map and
so on they were not always there they
have been added with all the updates
we've been introducing
dr. mystery our last question is the
curated information or data queue seed
yes yes absolutely so in terms of land
database it is Q seed at multiple
multiple places even before we decide to
bring data in we have QC process once
the reads are mapped to the references
you see process in terms of like how
many reads are mapped person how many
leaves are not mapped there's also QC in
terms of metadata curation and in terms
of IPS database there is also a QC
process so first of all we have PhD
level curators creating the information
and this information is part check
before it's added to the database so QC
parameters are applied at multiple
levels before the information is added
to this databases
I would like to once again thank dr.
mystery for his presentation I would
also like to thank haya Jen for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January of
2019 you will receive an email from
laborat when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon
goodbye